how is it for you who actually works in
a japanese company for the industry
different japanese companies before the
anime like something anime
the anime one yeah it's okay it's okay
it won't hurt you it's a microphone
i will kill you i don't know like if you
wanted me to say it's like exciting it's
nerd like nerdy no
just be honest be honest are the rumors
true are japanese companies
hell i'm joking
because there's like black companies
right gray yeah so like
japan has like this terminology where
it's like it's black where it's
white white is like they follow the
rules they treat their employees nice
and then black is like they overwork you
they ask you to work like i don't know
over time over time
but no like i got really lucky i think
the company i work with
i work for really like very
aggressive about telling their employees
go home you know
have a social life and they
like highly highly value that so
that's good what do you think about the
japanese like work life
schedule do you think like the as
someone who lives like i think it's on
average
that's crazy yeah yeah they work on
average 80 hours a
week yeah jesus christ 80 hours a week
how is like your work life schedule
compared to when you are
working outside of japan if you have any
comparisons
in well i only worked for an american
company in like san francisco
for a month before i quit and chase my
anime dreams
like can you really i guess based on
that one one month
experience it's very different like in
america i would just
clock out and leave that's that's yeah
yeah here it's
like you want to impress your supervisor
with good results and sometimes to get
those good results
i mean it doesn't necessarily make more
time but if you spend more time and do
more research like right maylene's a
hard worker yeah
i have no i mean maybe and then the
polar opposite you've got like the
scandinavian countries which are like
yeah
six hours a day is fine four days a week
yeah that seems good
but i mean it's been there's been plenty
of studies that prove that working more
doesn't necessarily mean more money
there's i mean there's studies to
actually prove
the opposite of that which is yeah yeah
exactly i mean that's where the whole
controversy of like the whole zongyour
uh you know thing comes from right where
like employees of like traditional
companies are
almost forced like socially it's not a
rule in the company but they're almost
socially
bound to stay back over time to work i
don't think they should though
not because they need to do the work but
because
as you said they want to impress their
supervisors right yeah kind of
but there are some times like i think
they really shouldn't stay behind even
if they're not really working or working
yeah it's because it really takes a toll
on their like mental health yeah for me
usually before an event
the month or month and a half i'm
actually working like really late like
11 pm or something because
crunch time type of thing yeah yeah and
i felt like
miserable during those times so i can
only imagine how miserable like
japanese people at japanese companies
that like do
they have their life i feel sorry yeah i
felt angry for no reason i'm like why am
i angry oh it's because
i'm am i working too much but i really
loved what i did
even if you love what you do though when
you get tired you you get
cranky i mean that's the same as us i
mean we we love our jobs it's always
working yeah but we're always working
and uh you know we never get a break but
even though we love what we do
there's times when i [ __ ] hate anime
you know you're just like
there are times where i'm just like i
don't want to work on this video
i just want to play games i know i know
watch porn or something like anything
else right to just get my mind off
that's what porn not even our porno
just watch it yeah this is one of those
days
what's a convention time like for you
then because
for us it's like especially ax it's busy
as hell but i've seen
people working in the industry working
[ __ ] over time when it comes to
convention season